good morning John so you want to know
what my primary concern is the one thing
above all that I care about more than
anything well I've gotta devote this
video to the top 10 celebrity side boob
shots of 2009 but you've taken that
dream away from me and not to mention
all of our adolescent teen male viewers
as you think YouTube is for discussing
ultimate concern everyone else thinks
it's for side boob pictures whatever
let's just go with what you want to do
so to determine my primary concern of
what I decided to do was think of the
first five things that I would give my
life for and then narrow it down from
there so that the five things that first
popped into my mind probably isn't all
the five things that popped into my mind
that I would give my life for are one my
wife which is much more selfish than you
think I mean she's the one that gets
stuck here without a best friend I
wouldn't want to be on the other side of
that deal number two freedom not mine
since I wouldn't be having the chance to
enjoy being dead but for the people I'd
care of I think I'd die for their
freedom before I died for their life to
resurrect the lost contents of the
massive library at Alexandria number
four to make peaceful contact with a
nonhuman sentient race from another
world because I'm a huge dork number
five free non polluting energy for
everyone
something just occurred to me meet me on
the floor for a tangent one thing that I
would not give my life for is to be the
first person to break the sound barrier
while skydiving Felix Baumgartner who
isn't a bit of an idiot is going to try
and do this soon by jumping out of a
helium balloon that is 23 miles into the
air the air is so thin up there that
there's nothing to slow him down so he
will eventually reach the speed of sound
and he will break it and no one knows
what the shockwave is going to do to his
body he may die I hope he doesn't but he
recognizes that he may die so apparently
jumping out of a helium balloon 23 miles
above the earth is Felix Baumgartner's
ultimate concern okay back to the chair
ah my goal is to take those five things
that I would die for and then have a
tournament between them and I would have
to choose like a terrorist would show up
and he'd be like the contents of the
library at Alexandria or your wife which
one do I destroy and then I would have
to choose and by narrowing it down that
way I would figure out what my ultimate
concern was but I've been working on
this video and trying to do it and I
can't do
so to answer your question I don't know
what my ultimate concern is I don't even
know that it's that interesting to me I
think I find a much more interesting to
think about what I am concerned with it
all like where do I draw the line where
is the line between stuff that I would
die for and stuff that I would fight for
and stuff that I care at all about and
then stuff out here that I don't care at
all about at all like out here is rocks
but there are some rocks that are in
here like diamonds I think we all would
work for diamonds but most rocks are out
here but like the rocks that compose the
Grand Canyon may be pretty close to the
stuff that I would die for but you can't
care about everything you can't bring
everything into the fold and you can't
care about the baby of the crazy
neighbor across the street as much as I
care about Henry that's what I think is
interesting I think concern is
interesting and always very central to
the stuff that I'm concerned about is
going to be my family which is why I
have to say happy birthday mom thank you
for being born and for making John and I
and mom I wrote you a little song using
party blowers the rest of the world
celebrates mama greens birthday by
wearing green clothes and dyeing beard
and rivers green she's a very special
lady everybody takes notice if you think
they're celebrating the st. Patrick's
guy you got another thing coming but you
may enjoy this episode of truth avail
that I just did John I will see you on
Friday
your first set of facts fact one there
is one four-leaf clover for every 100
regular three leaf clovers or fact -
according to legend st. Patrick used the
symbol of the Shamrock to represent the
Holy Trinity - the pagan Irish people
that he was trying to convert
you